Hell no okay so okay so look look look
They went from a thousand five they went
from 11,000 to I mean I said 11,000 my bad
they went from 1100 so we was at 2,000
Well hello let me cut it down and I don't
want to yell over there and the TV
I didn't realize how loud I was
No one said how do I cut it off
So I told them to be aggressive cuz it was
taken too long and then I fell asleep and
then when I woke up it was only 69 pounds
And I'm not really mad cuz he left most of
the working messages system it left the
Discord devlog
And all of this stuff is in the get history
It's my fault though cuz I shouldn't have
let him
I shouldn't have let him run overnight
aggressively like that but I wanted action I
wanted it now
I wanted to wake upI guess I woke up to
exactly what I asked for man.
They deleted all but the essential valves
And now we're down to 69
So it's time to get him up to 300
There are things that they took out that I
want to get back and so the first thing I
want to get back is the working theater
implementation if you see this screen
scrolling that's me doing that it says in
now
That'sWhat I would call agent for.
And so the top left corner would be one top
right two bottom left three and then I'm
working on four right now I'd have it going
through to get history just looking
To see I should have pointed it directly at
the get released but
We already found what we were looking for
And this time I'm making sure that each file
is V2 compliantFrom the jump so.
This is V3
You can't say Spartan
Some say this is SpartaBut I'm only a
keyboard Warrior this is V3 you can't say
that.
WhatOkay. Let's just let's just this is me
through let's just keep it simple.
Mexico
Good night yes
Jane Witt
This message is brought to you by Apple
cardboard
.com
Thank you
For Haley boy
PunishingThey do stupid.
What you do with that happened
Stupid
Again
Dreaming
It's
Facebook pictures
OK Google
What happened to those pancakes good time to
start thanks guys thanks for starting those
pancakes right now appreciate you
?
I'll check on Facebook
Hey I found you
What
Watching your Facebook Center
If you cry the watering punch me open till
we sing give me the bowl
I didThat you're going to take it.
GoogleIt looks too loose from what I just
sent. It looked too loose from what I just
seen missing.
Nah she looseIt looks too loose.
Disbursement
Google
WhatWhat.
Chris why do you got to be so loud though
are you trying to be heard on the mic
Okay Chris
Joe
No I'm letting you know cuz when I got to
yell at you that's embarrassingSo.
Chris let me know if you come in there
bugging you anymoreChris.
Let me know if you come in there bugging you
anymore
You go outside
Chicken breast
Where's my phone can we put it on a good
charger
Oh yeah for basketball tomorrow
Do I get a sport or something
I care about is this flipping keep doingYou
want to watch it.
I'm sorry
The flip you keep doing puts it on the
battery and you see that battery people
could taste it but other than that it's
going to be good
With love yourPancakes. Sound like.
Christopher Robin
You want my pancake
Because
Want the restThank you.
At home I used to make pancakes hotI was
doing it in there that's why I made them
like that.
I've been making it like that for a long
time
I'm going to try to make them how you make
them
Because that's why you make umbrella
You hear me Chris
I'm talking about
Photos
Please
Understand
It's not
So far
No
What they say
Music
Probability
TextSuccess Roman has.
To
Do you know where the blue scissors are
You
And they can't use it
Chicken losing for not being fasting and if
you going to get fast
HahaDo you love me.
Do it oh man the camera is on
Peppa Pig
Charlie do me a favor since you're upAnd you
bring me my hat. It's right over there.
It's something underneath my head is right
over thereAnd then you trying to play for
tonight.
I'm asking a question
Charlie they gave me school supplies
Can you do me one last favor can you cut on
myMicrophone.
I need my speaker
Man
What's upWhy are you plugging that up it's
the black one I'm in the blue one.
Never mindSuper 300.
Oh yeah this is for my breakfast